miley though has been money his numbers
from western and southern well you
always hope that dave that wade miley is
going to to pitch the way he has been
pitching because he's been on quite a
role but when you look inside the
challenge that he faces today he's faced
these cardinal hitters a lot and there
are a number of hitters in this lineup
that in the past have given him a lot of
problems guys like nolan aronado and
paul goldschmidt particularly the
right-handers that are in this lineup
that have done some damage to him before
he knows that going into this ball game
but he's not going to change his game
plan he's going to go with what works
for him cutter change up occasional
fastball and work fast
tommy edmond
to third base mustache bouncer nice pick
by joey ivano
warmer arizona diamondbacks goldschmidt
and miley facing each other
and goldie lifts it in the air out to
center nakequin back one nothing on a
bomb
an absolute bomb by goldie he picks up
right where he left off in the month of
august home run number 23.
a home run by goldschmidt the base hit
for o'neal and here's nolan arnotto
down on strikes first k for miley
miley's first pitch to sosa chopped
toward the middle farmer fields under
hands to india covering its second base
to force out carlson's side retired good
to see this guy back miles michaelis
getting the start for st louis it is
good to see him back making his fourth
start of the year third since coming
back off the il the hyundai pitch
arsenal here for miles michaelis you'll
see a good amount of the four seam and
the two seam mixed in good slider cutter
that he throws effectively to lefties
and righties good curveball to change up
as well so
the hope for miles here is just go
attack
inside corner comes back to get him in a
strikeout for michaelis like i said you
can spot up inside right there dan
there's tyler naked when he has been one
of the hottest hitters in baseball
3-2 pitch
the fly ball
out to harrison bader and center backing
up to make the catch
first two have been retired
two and a strikeout miles strikes out
two and the bottom of the first one
nothing harrison vader to lead things
off against lefty wade miley that one is
hit out to deep left it's at the wall
god
it's a home run
harrison bader
it's a pair of solo shots against wayne
miley and it adds up to a two-nothing st
louis lead
a single by kisner giving michaelis a
chance to advance the runner
go for broke
novato will flip to india advancing on
the play kisner from first to second
tommy edmond has driven in 45 runs all
for one with a ground out to third
leading off the game
chops hit left side backhanded by the
shortstop farmer
and gets tommy edmond tyler o'neal
socked the first pitch he saw in the
left field for a single in the first
inning
got him
strike out of tyler o'neal cardinal
strand a pair the reds have two on with
one out and here's tucker barnhart
grounded to the open shortstop hole wave
is on bottom
o'neill from left lobs to third bono
scores and the reds on the board a base
hit for pornhart it's two to one so now
it's up to the pitcher wade miley will
stand in
and there's another miley base knock
farmer scores to tie the game bart hart
the wave
barnhart scores
miley mania
a two-run double and the reds lead three
to two
he's not going the three two pitches hit
into right field for a hit base hit and
aronado rounds second he's headed for
third and the cardinals open the top of
the third inning with a base hit to left
and a base hit to right and there's
nobody out for edmundo sosa
and sosa sends a fly ball into shallow
right catch made by castiano spins and
throws aronado tags up and scores easily
and we're tied 3-3 they got one of those
runs back and they're threatening for
more andrew kisner
first pitch farmer to india one big
pivot
relay in time double play
joey bottom four pitch walk his first
time
and he rockets one to right center
that's down base hit all the way to the
wall castigato's through second vader
gathers spins and throws in wave is on
the challenge the relay to the play
castellanos
he avoided the tag of kissner
and the reds lead again four to three
volvo up to second paul boltzmann at the
plate what the cardinals need to do here
in the fourth inning is jump all over
miley the way the reds did in the bottom
of the second against michaelis
and goldie lifts a high fly ball and a
right center he's done it again
oh my
in the right center his second home run
in this game he's up to 24 and the
cardinals are back on top
five for st louis
tyler o'neill's down at second base he's
there with two outs as dylan carlson
hits here
big bound farmer adjusted well
back and forth in this seesaw battle
paul goldschmidt delivers again
and the new pitcher is lucas sims
swing into this struck him out
a slider slider slider 96.
one bull one strike count here to the
right-handed hitting harrison bader
lifted on the infield
and it will be
andrew kisner who is catching for yadier
molina here in game one
strikeout nonetheless
book and case for sims in a perfect
fifth
three four and five do up for the red
legs so in the pitcher spot david bell
goes to a eugenio suarez
into field down face head fair ball
suarez turns goldschmidt gathers fire on
the second to base the slide safe
hustle double off the bench hey eugenio
suarez and aristides aquino will bat
with two outs and the tying run at
second base against luis garcia
aquino breaks his bat
and a soft liner to tommy edmond garcia
another scoreless zenic sends us to the
seventh of game one this is the final
hope for cincinnati
and it's a chance for giovanni gallegos
to pick up another save guy goes to
india
the fly ball
out to center
alejo lopez batting left-handed against
giovanni gallegos with one out the
one-two pitch
he got him two away
here in the bottom of the seventh of
game one nicholas
castiano's the final hope for cincinnati
fly ball
shallow center bader is there
the cardinals take game one of the
double header there now a game and a
half back of cincinnati game two coming
up tonight man this is what it's all
about you got baseball all day long the
cardinals are pulling close goldie have
yourself a day a couple of home runs
bullpen comes in clutch for the
cardinals giving them four scoreless